hello in this video we'll talk about
inner immune system and this is going to
be a overview of the innate immune
system
so innate immunity refers to the
non-specific defense response of our
immune system
that is evoked just after few seconds
pathogen has invaded our body
so the components of the inner immune
system
involves effector molecules
and cellular components
inside the cellular components there are
many cell types
such as macrophages dendritic cells
neutrophil
nk cells mast cells eosinophils and
many of them and inside the effected
molecule category there are
complement proteins and cytokines
if you wish to know that how these
cellular components are
evolved or how these cellular components
are generated
so you can watch my video and the link
is given in the i button
let's talk about the functions of the
inner immune
system so first of all their job is to
recognize
pathogen secondly they know how to
engulf the pathogen and they would try
at least to destroy the pathogen
thirdly they have to alarm other immune
component cell
such that they can also come and
together can lead to a stronger
immune response lastly their job is to
coordinate
with the adaptive immune system and let
the adaptive immune system know
about the nature of the pathogen
so first job is to do recognition
and recognition is done by specific
receptors present on macrophages
dendritic cell or even b
cells so what aspects
of the pathogen does these cell type
determine
it turns out they determine something is
known as pam
pathogen associated molecular pattern
in simple words these are molecular
signatures of the pathogen which
which is determined by the receptors
present on the macrophages or dendritic
cell
so let's talk about this thing in bit
more details we are looking at a
dendritic cell here which is displaying
a pathogen derived antigen on
class 2 mhc molecule now before it can
display the pathogen-derived antigen it
has to understand
at the first place that it's a pathogen
and that is done
with the help of pattern recognition
receptors one of them
is total light receptors tone like
receptors
are generally known as pattern pattern
recognition receptor
so they detect pamps or pathogen
associated molecular patterns which
could be bacterial protein
dna or even other kind of enzymes
so there are quite a lot of tlr present
on the dendritic cell
such as tlr 1 and 2 which is responsible
for detection of
bacteria and parasites tlr 2 and 6
which is responsible for detection of
gram positive bacteria and fungi
so note this that these tlr's can homo
diameterize
and heterodimerase in this case both of
these tlr are heterodimer
now there are homodimer tlr such as tlr5
which determines bacterial flagella and
also tlr4 which determines
cellular components of gram-negative
bacteria such as
lipopolysaccharide there are many
doll-like receptors which are also
present in
endosomes such as tlr4 tlr9
tlr7 and tlr3 and many of these things
are responsible for
determining intracellular pathogen so
most of them determine viral rna viral
dna etc so now we have a overview of
what type of
pattern recognition receptor is present
on the dendritic cell surface
now let's try to understand the process
of detection
so the process of detection is basically
an intricate
signaling pathway where the pathogen
derived molecular pattern is
bound to the toll like receptor and
after binding there are signaling
pathways which are initiated the first
component of this signaling pathway is
myeloid differentiation factor 88 which
signals to the nucleus and leads to
several gene activation
so let us look at this process in bit
more details so first of all
after binding to pam my d88 is recruited
my d88 activates several kinases such as
iraq and traffic
this further leads to activation of nf
capability which is the key player in
this signaling pathway
and nf kappa beta is a transcriptional
activator so it can migrate into the
nucleus
and leads to transcription of several
genes
out of many genes that is transcribed by
nf capabilities the major ones are
several cytokine genes such as il1 il-6
tnf alpha etc but there are other tlr
which are present in the endocytotic
vesicles
these tlr signals via a different
signaling pathway
which involves interferon response
factor
irf 7 or 3 and this is also a
transcriptional activator which can
activate different set of genes and
thereby mediate the response
so depending upon the pathogen the tlr
signaling would be also different
and it would lead to different kind of
cytokine production either cytokine
production or interferon production
so let us try to understand other type
of pattern recognition receptors that
are present
on the surface of dendritic cell or
these kind of inner immune cells
these pattern recognition receptor are
c-type lectin receptor
or clrs these clr signal with the help
of
card9 which is a caspase recruitment
domain nine and
ultimately it leads to activation of nf
kappa beta
and then nf capability leads to genetic
changes
there are other kind of like pattern
recognition receptors such as rlr
which is known as rig i like receptor
this rlr their ligand is generally
different kind of viral or bacterial rna
they determine the rna and ultimately
through a
intricate signaling pathway leads to
activation of irf7 r3
which can lead to specific set of gene
expression
other than this there is nlr or nod like
receptor
node like receptor works via several
separate pathway
and it activates ap one family of
transcription factors which can
give rise to a separate set of gene
expression so
the common theme between all of these
kind of pattern recognition receptor is
they are dedicated
to recognize a class of pathogen-derived
molecular pattern and they respond
via different set of gene expression so
all the cases they will have a different
type of response
now let's talk about the clr in a bit
more details
so clrs are super important in terms of
determining fungal pathogens
so when there is a fungal infection clr
activates specific
genes which creates inflammation but all
of these clr's
are not involved in inflammatory
response so this is
not a generalization because many clr
such as dectin
are important for reduction of
interleukin 1
6 interleukin-12 etc but another
clr which is known as dc sign leads to
suppression of these genes of these
pro-inflammatory genes
so they can work by activation of
inflammatory cytokines also
they can work by inhibiting these
inflammatory cytokine genes
now the biggest problem with inner
immune system
is they have limited specificity for
example this tlr4 molecule would be
determining lipopolysaccharides
but it cannot tell us that this
lipopolysaccharide is coming from which
strain of
bacteria so that is why they have
limited specificity
so they can tell that it is coming from
a bacteria
but between different strains of
bacteria it cannot discriminate
and that is why we need a more specific
immune system
which is done by our adaptive immune
system so if you want to learn more
about adaptive immune system you can
click on the link
which you would find in the i button
so let's talk about the recognition part
so first of all there would be
recognition
of these pathogen associated molecular
patterns
and then it would be
coordinated with the adaptive immune
system components
now this adaptive immune system
component would eventually mount
a specific immune response
so here is a dendritic cell which is
recognizing some bacteria
as a pathogen then they would first
engulf this pathogen
and after engulfing pathogen with the
help of
lysosome these pathogens would be
degraded and their components would be
displayed
on the class 2 mhc molecules because
dendritic cells are
classical antigen presenter cells now
these dendritic cells have to coordinate
with the adaptive immune system and
that's why it would migrate
all the way along to lymph node
and inside the lymph node there are
specific regions for t cells and b
cells so in the paracortex area this
particular dendritic cell would activate
t cells
t cells would eventually activate b
cells which can further
be generate plasma cells and ultimately
these
b cells can also proliferate a lot
and give rise to long-lived plasma cells
so all this coordination
between innate and adaptive immune
system is only possible by a dendritic
cell
other component of the inner immune
system is the complement
pathway now complement proteins can coat
the bacteria
and make it less harmful or make it less
active so this is called opsinization
these bacterias are now opsinized
and these oxidized bacteria can
ultimately
be destroyed with the help of complement
pathway so first of all there is
antibody mediated complement fixation
which lead to recruitment of
several component proteins and there is
a
poor formation in the membrane which is
known as membrane attack complex
so the membrane attack complex leads to
fluid leakage which
eventually leads to bursting of this
pathogen and thereby the pathogen is
destroyed so this is one way
by which inner immune system can destroy
the pathogen
but point to be noted that this
complement fixation pathway
is not specific it can be same
irrespective of any kind of
bacterial strain now
another important function of inner
immune system
is to alarm other components of the
immunity
for example in this case the dendritic
cell and the macrophage has recognized
some pathogens and now they want to
send the alarm signal and they are
calling for
backup so this signal is received by the
cells which are circulating in the
bloodstream
such as this neutrophil this neutrophil
would sense this signal
and then change its cytoskeletal
rearrangement
to move out of this blood vesicle
and come into the tissue space and there
are other chemokine
mediated factors which allow this
neutrophil to find their way
towards the infection site and thereby
neutrophil can join these macrophages
and dendritic cell to fight pathogen
further
so this is how they are calling for
backup
after that there is another component
which is a
cold blood killer and the lethal weapon
of the immune system which is known as
nk cell or natural killer cell
natural killer cells are born to kill
there are many important features of
natural killer cell if you want a
detailed video on that you can click on
the link
natural killer cell have set of
activatory and
inhibitory receptor they are highly
loaded with phagocytotic granules which
are
loaded with enzymes that can degrade
pathogens or other cell types
they have a signature nk 1.1 surface
receptor
they also have fc receptor and fast
ligands
now whenever there is a class 1 mhc
derived peptide
nk cell would not engage
right so nk cells inherent tendency is
to
kill the pathogen but when there is a
inhibitory signal which is provided by
this class 1 mhc and inhibitory receptor
interaction
then kcl would disengage but when class
1 mhc mediated peptides are not
displayed
nk cells are super angry and now they
would engage
and thereby killing the pathogen
along with the cell type so nk cells
will destroy the whole
cell and all the pathogens which are
intracellular to this cell would be
destroyed
and that is how nkcl kills pathogen and
it's also
non-specific but very effective
component and they have
very high killing potential so
in this video we learned about how
inner immune system components recognize
pathogen
how they can engulf and destroy these
pathogens
thirdly we learn how they can send alarm
signals such that other immune
components can be recruited into the
site of infection
and lastly we looked at how they can
interact with the adaptive immune system
components
such that they can coordinate a specific
and a stronger immune response so i hope
you enjoyed this video if you like this
video give it a quick thumbs up don't
forget to like share and subscribe my
channel
you can also support me by paying me in
patreon
and my courses are present in unacademy
so you can always join academy and using
my code ap 10 you can get a 10
discount thank you guys thanks for
listening